okay so today we're gonna talk about
cross-device experiences and try to get
insight about making them more fluid so
the you know Microsoft has dislike line
of surface devices right the studio de
pro the gold hub and basically we have
that vision of people working together
you know like on these days you know
across multiple devices multiple people
in fact the reality is quite different
from this in fact if you look at this
just one person they already have a
number of devices that they work with
and then you see another I think
technical term for this is like Messi
you have like multiple devices you have
your mobile phone you have maybe tablets
you have your laptop you bring it from
home then if you add other people to the
mix it's even worse right but you also
have you know a lot of material that's
actually paper you have printed
reference material you have like loose
paper and notebooks for you take notes
on so basically it's you know from that
study even from 2013 but even nowadays
is probably even worse that you still
have sort of a messy environment and if
you look beyond the actual physical
objects and the ecology of software
that's out there to enable you to share
files and work on them is also sort of
messy if you see that study they were
actually looking at how people share the
file with collaborators by email but
they keep a version on their laptop and
then they have another version and
synchronized from their desktop so
really when you're working with other
people and even with just yourself on
multiple files the whole process is sort
of not fluid and so the my interest my
recent interest is to really look at the
knowledge worker workflow and by
knowledge worker I mean people who are
using Word Excel in a word like office
products and then really trying to
understand what they're doing with
across all those products and all of
those devices
another simple observation is that
a lot of the files that people create on
multiple devices or just multiple apps
actually contain different pieces of
information that one needs to sort of
put together cross reference and relates
in order to provide evidence for
decision-making for example or to put
together a talk like I did today so they
need to sort of decide oh that
information is in separate file and some
of our work investigated how we can
reintegrate the ink and the digital pen
in that process and I'm just going to
show you sneak peek video so just to
make a little bit of cool factor to the
beginning of that session our latest
work that looked at basically how we can
relate different sources of information
so here imagine I've annotated document
that's based on several data sources and
I've used my digital link there and so
what's cool about the digital versus the
analog one is if I just interact with it
I can basically relate the source of
that information that is related to my
document so here about bringing out back
for example the Excel data spreadsheet
and this basically can extend beyond the
multiple apps right it naturally goes
with different sources of information
coming from different devices or
different people so for example I have a
couple of files on my surface probably I
have also information that I want relate
from my meeting with with on the surface
hub with my team and here we started
looking at different cross device
interactions such as underlining a piece
of information like while on relaxing on
the sofa and I go and then later
retrieving that piece of information on
a larger surface at work so for example
here by searching of shapes that you can
bookmark information with I can retrieve
say a chart I've seen in Excel a
paragraph that had in Word and then that
line that I did underlined on my surface
go in my email and so I have this like
larger set of device to turn of this
larger device to sort of interact and
think
with my data so we're sort of at a
crossroad here if we started just
investigated sort of this workflow of
knowledge worker but we don't really
have enough information about what to do
cross device to make this really fluid
and this is actually the goal of that
panel today is to get the perspective
from experts in the field the master of
the cross device experiences and we are
so lucky to have four of them today and
each will give a unique insight in some
of the possibilities to enable those
fluid cross device experiences and so
our first speaker today is so Greenberg
from University of Calgary come so so so
is a faculty professor an emeritus
professor in the department of computer
science at University of Calgary is work
is at the intersection of HCI computer
CCW Calibri while I can never know this
one well collaborative work and giving
each is computing he has so many papers
and the words I will just say that
you're lucky to hear him to the give us
insight about this device experiences or
think before you go okay can you just
take that sure okay thanks what do you
just saw me get giving her was piece of
paper that was extremely lightweight
extremely easy and essentially that's
was a cross device experience where I
transferred information from my hands to
her hands and the devices with her hands
so what I'm going to talk about today is
essentially how can we use social
science our natural asked to design
fluid cross device experiences so a big
challenge in interaction design is how
to fluidly transfer content across
devices for example from tablets to
large displays or between tablets held
by the same or different people or in
fact between any of the devices we we
now carry or have in the world around us
so the message I wanted to deliver is
that social science theory can inform or
inspire the design of socially natural
fluid cross device experiences that is
I'm
going to advocate a socially centric
versus a technology centric approach to
design so let's start by considering a
small space ecology just as similar to
what Nathalie showed before so you
become C's people within ecology of
devices phones tablets large displays
and other appliances and the problem is
that it's incredibly awkward and
difficult to interconnect these devices
let alone interact and transfer content
between them in a cohesive manner so
just think back to the last time you
tried to share a photo with a friend and
how awkward it could be I know that for
my my purposes I often end up using
email or Dropbox or some other
mechanisms with it with with an iphone
to try to do it and it's doable but it's
painful so I want you to imagine a new
kind of ubiquitous computing environment
where there's an ecology of devices that
react to people's social expectations in
a way that facilitates natural social
practice that is the device has become
social actors so what I'm really talking
about is exploiting social sciences as
the method to inspire the design of
interactive systems so to do this I'm
going to begin with a first fairly old
but simple social science theory where
we take advantage of people's natural
expectations of spatial relations and
that's called proxemics so in the 1960s
an anthropologist Edward Hall defined
the notion of proxemics
that is how people that manage their
interpersonal space and his basic theory
is very simple it correlates physical
distance to social distance now this is
something we all know tacitly especially
when it's violated so here's some images
a past President Lyndon Johnson was
known for his domineering personalities
and in what became known as the Johnson
treatment he would intensely penetrate
people's personal space as seen in the
series of photos of him interacting with
the senator it was said that his
treatment was rule rude bullying
improper annoying but effective that is
he used his knowledge of proxemics as a
power relationship
now more formally and perhaps more
naturally Edward Hall described the
series of zones around people so
starting from the inside we have the
intimate zone and characterized by those
two lovers in the upper corner over
there moving out a bit we have the
personal zone
that's where close friends and
colleagues are situated relative to one
another as they converse again is shown
by that wonderful statue up in that the
corner that you're looking at somewhat
outside is the social zone and that's
where acquaintances usually sit so that
photo that you see there shows us really
well the two girls and two guys are in
each other's personal zone but the girls
and guys are separated in their social
Jonze that so in social zone that shows
a bit of distance between them and
finally we have the public razón
reserved for things like strangers
occupying a space where people tend to
separate themselves by distance when
they can and we could even see that in
this room here
some people think where you see friends
together but you also see people finding
their own space now there are of course
many other attributes that come into
play when interpreting proxemic use and
one of them is called gradual engagement
and that's how we signal how people
become aware and grouse you move toward
each other to engage in interaction so
gradual engagement begins with mutual
awareness of each other's presence a
greetings to acknowledge that presence
an approach and interaction using that
social zone or or intimate zone and then
a disengagement people's orientation to
one another can also signal social
engagement or disengagement which is
clearly visible in those two contrasting
photos same distance different level of
involvement identity helps define past
relationships and determine and
interpret current relationships and that
needs to be considered as well there's
also environmental features for example
the fixed features of a space that
communicate territories or boundaries
like rooms doorways signals distance
different distances for example a person
outside a doorway is seen as more
distance than a person inside a doorway
the environment can also contain
semi-fixed features that can be
configured to encourage or discourage
interactivity for example this seating
encourages small group activity where
whereas changing it to this seating
arrangement somewhat discourages it
context is also critical for
interpreting proxemic use is shown here
by contrasting a home versus the crowded
subway setting but in spite of all this
we can still consider proximity and a
few other attributes as a reasonable
first approximation of social engagement
now let's now see how he news parks be
proxemics to inspire design where I'm
going to show you how I and a whole
bunch of other colleagues some of our on
this panel use these theories to inform
and inspire the design of cross-device
experiences now the basic idea is that
both people and the devices they carry
are consider social actors each obeying
the rules or proxemics so as computer
scientist the first question we had to
answer was how to operate how to
operationalize proxemics as metrics we
could capture from our environment and
the result was five dimensions between
people and their devices we can capture
the distance between them the relative
orientation their movement toward or
away from each other their identity and
also contextual information about the
location and without getting into
details of how these were captured by
our technology the examples that follow
sense some are all of these and these
metrics to enable social rules that
drive cross-device interaction so our
first test bed which is now fairly old
was a proxemic media player which
recognizes the proxemic relations
between a person a handheld media player
that they carry that contains content
and a large display let's take a look we
illustrate this using a media sharing
functionality between a portable digital
media device and the large surface the
system provides awareness and for me
regarding sharing possibilities while
the device is at a distance an icon
representing the portable device on the
large screen changes its position and
size depending on the orientation and
distance of the portable device to the
screen full access and information
exchange is possible once the person
brings the device close to the screen so
what we saw in that clip was not only
the use of proximity but a design
pattern based on that notion of gradual
engagement I mentioned earlier that is
as a person and as their device gets
closer to one or to each other it
signals the awareness of the device
presence and a connectivity in the
social zone the reveal of exchangeable
content in the personal zone and then it
offers interaction methods to transfer
content into each zone so let's take a
look at a somewhat similar example that
explicitly shows these stages of gradual
engagement because it's important that
you see them too to understand how that
works when a person enters the room an
icon on the lodge display indicates the
cameras presence as the person moves
closer to the display the image is
stored on the camera are progressively
revealed until gesture allows for
scrolling through the images these
images then can be copied to the display
using direct touch so those examples
show one person doing cross device
interaction so let's now see how this
applies to two or more people exchanging
content between their handheld devices
and also through a public display let me
just get this here the person in just
the room sorry I'm doing some here we go
okay so this is start so here people
maintain awareness of surrounding
devices by icons I've moved to show
their relative location and this helps
in a cluttered environment to find out
what they can interact with the same
icon serves as portals for a technique
called collaborative handoff so here one
person offers content by dragging it
onto the portal and the other person
accepts it by dragging it off their
portal and that's some very similar to
this the
lack of giving and taking and offers a
degree of security as one person offers
to the other and then takes it here's
another example where those rectangles
shows a person content are their their
personal device and here they're
dragging it onto the public display
which serves as the intermediary and the
other person accepts it by dragging it
into their own display now Proximus is
just one social theory involving
people's spatial relationships but are
there there are other related social
theories that we can use to tune that
interaction even further so I'm going to
introduce you to to two other theories
very busy called affirmations and micro
mobility so take a look at this photo
and quickly what do you see well you'll
likely see three groups all are not only
defined by proxemics but by the way the
group's orient themselves and create a
shared space between them and that's us
what the socialist Theory called F
formations is all about so a typical F
formation arrangement is a roughly
circular cluster of several people the
inner space of that circle is was called
the overlap space and that's reserved
for the main activity the group is
pursuing so it's kind of like their
shared working area the ring of space
occupied by the by the people is the
participant space and that determines
group membership and this is where
people stand the surrounding region
buffers the group from the outside world
so people who are nearby but not in the
participant space are excluded from the
social circle but still monitored to see
who may be trying to join now a second
social theory is much more fine-grained
I'll just briefly mention it now and
it's called micro mobility that is how
people manipulate items in that overlap
space to indicate the degree that those
items are shared owned and handed off to
one another for example take a look at
this doctor with a medical chart and the
way they're holding it here it's clear
that that that chart is owned by them
and that they're looking at it is not
for the patient and yet a slight change
in the angle of that chart indicates an
intent to share that information with
that other person and of course an even
further
movement of that chart toward the person
signals that it's it's an offer to them
to take it so let's briefly consider how
all this fits together for cross-device
experiences we can use proximity to
detect social engagement we detect
affirmations to define groups and to
create Federation's between the devices
they carry excluding those outside the
affirmations to safeguard privacy and
security and we can monitor device by
chrome ability to define appropriate
cross device interaction within that
information so here's an early example
illustrating how affirmations that micro
bility can be applied to design
interaction techniques for subtle cross
device context content transfer that was
done by our next one of our speakers
Nick when he was interning with Ken at
Microsoft in specific spatial
arrangements that facilitate
communication so-called affirmations
examples of these formations are people
standing side by side corner to corner
or face to face when interacting with
another our system monitors people's
distance and orientation relative to
each other around them and observes any
formations between them the system then
leverage the knowledge about people's
formations to allow people to easily
share information to a person standing
next to them where's a person standing
at the same distance but facing away
from the formation is excluded from the
lightweight Federation of devices we
developed for interaction techniques
allowing people to share information
while standing next to each other
information first the Tilted preview
technique shows a temporary copy of the
touched item when a person tells that
have it towards the second person
touching the item on the other tablet
let's the second person keeps a
permanent copy second our face to mirror
technique lets a person mirror the
currently largest item on their screen
to the other person's tablet when
holding it vertically again touching the
item keeps a permanent copy
third : edges appear when a person tells
that habit towards another person
dragging an item onto these edges
so-called portals moves it to the other
person's tablet form with a cross device
pinch-to-zoom technique people can use
any item on the combined viewing area of
multiple tablets so what's key to all
those that to try to get the socially
natural experience we have to detect
that information and it's enacted only
on the devices that are part of that
Federation and it'll base that you rules
the micro mobility so that's a preview
so in closing this talk was all about
advocating social science theory as a
way to inform the design of socially
natural cross-device experiences and I
hope that becomes part of our discussion
but I also believe that discussion
should concern dark patterns as
researchers we design with our white
hats on for the good to improve human
experiences the problem is that we
should also expect black designs based
on proxemic interactions that don't have
the users best interest in mind so we
have identified some of these and just
to kind of give you an example of a
black hat thing here's a video of an
existing system called which it's
embracing the pattern called the
attention grabber which tries to take
over a person's device to attract their
attention when Phoebe enters a
participating store her phone instantly
recognizes the in-store shopping signal
and because she's opted in it reminds
her to open the shop kick app and get
walking reward kicks it also shows her
how many items she's liked at that store
while Phoebe shops the shopping app can
tell her about special offers and deals
in the app can even remind her of the
item she's liked in department she
visits
so I'll just let you decide of that part
of the future you want thank you very
much thank you so here I took care of it
so thank you so much do we have a
question for Saul
we'll have a lot of discussion perhaps
at the end with all of our speakers but
if we have like a particular question on
that topic I'd like to take it now wait
hi Lucy Fortson University of Minnesota
so what are the issues around social
norms and the social theories that would
underlie all of this so I understand
that yeah I think that's a sufficient
question yeah so it's interesting that
the person who first talked about
proxemics theory was an anthropologist
and his actual research was about
differences in how different cultures
used proxemic cues and some culture is
different the distance meant very
different things so I completely agree
if what you're really asking in a sense
is that there's a one measure that we
use for everyone and the answer is
unlikely on the other hand what we are
talking about is not a strict
requirement that we exactly obey the
rules of social of our social norms
we're talking about using this to
inspire design so I think we can relax
that quite a bit
as long as it's very clear as what our
technology is trying to do so there's a
balance point in there devices aren't
people and I think people will accept
that and will relax their expectations
somewhat and that's probably thank you
thank you so see you soon
all right thank you very much
our next speaker is Nicola Marquardt and
all of the other letters is an associate
professor in physical computing at the
University College London his research
is really cross-disciplinary is done
physical user interfaces is done cross
device interaction ubiquitous computing
is also a master sketcher and it does
beautiful sketchnoting of your talks one
of his actually book on like sketching
user experience I think you are on that
book too bill maybe you should check out
it's about sketching for HCI and yes
also numerous publication in Awards and
I'm so happy that you're here Nick today
good morning everyone it's my pleasure
to be here with you today and telling
you a bit more about our work and
cross-device interactions now as we've
seen but the many examples shown in
Saul's talk the feel of cross device
computing is investigating how we can
move beyond interaction with a single
device and instead design for
interactions that span across the larger
ecology of devices and people and the
goal is technology that works in concert
to best support the task at hand now
much work has been done on designing and
studying cross device interactions
mostly in the past 10 to 15 years
leading to a disconnected terminology
and techniques creating an overall
fragmented research landscape and with a
goal to unify some part of that large
large space of techniques and systems
and it to inform future research we
worked on creating a taxonomy of cross
device interactions for this we analyzed
over 500 papers and the cross device
interaction domain to synthesize
techniques strategies and common
patterns and the photo here shows our
attempt how our Templar Knight lore ghen
eyes our findings across any available
space in our office now what I'm
planning to do now over the next 15
minutes is that I would like to unpack
this taxonomy a little bit to give you
an overview of the research space in
particular out of our analysis of
terminology application system
evaluations and techniques I want to
guide you through three specific parts
of our techs on
and with this I would like to answer and
give answers and address three
particular questions first what does the
field of course device interaction look
like second what are techniques we can
use for designing fluid cross device
interactions and third I'd like to give
you a few pointers of open issues and
opportunities of where we can go next
now this work the taxonomy in the many
examples I'll show you in the next 15
minutes have been work have been work
that we were done with a whole number of
collaborators in particular many parts
that you that you see today are based on
the work of my PG student Frederick buoy
so let me start with the overview of the
field the work resample in our talks on
a taxonomy covered people's interactions
across a wide spectrum of different
technology from laptops phones tablets
all the way to large interactive
surfaces tangibles and augmented or
virtual reality and not surprisingly
that Herman terminology used was quite
diverse we try to untangle this in the
visual summary you can see here and the
main takeaways here are that cross
device interactions range across a broad
spectrum of device form factors and that
besides the more traditional screen
based devices the research increasingly
includes categories such as tangibles
wearables and AR VR headsets now second
is that the diverse terms that that are
used then such as multi device cross
surface distributed or multi mobile
interaction often outline and target
specific focused areas but let us have a
closer look at the characteristics of
those interactions now in our main
taxonomy overview we identified a number
of categories of cross device
configurations from mirror to
distributed user interfaces all the way
to migratory and cross platform
interfaces and I'll explain a few of
them shortly they fall into two main
categories interactions can either be
synchronous when interactions have met
the same time or asynchronous with a
sequential flow of interactions across
devices and the large majority of the
work we sampled in our survey falls into
the first synchronous category besides
the temporal and configuration
characteristics there are four more
dimensions that we can see here at the
bottom the relationship of people and
devices and so on mentioned many
examples that that that address that
category in particular the scale they
interact
the dynamics of the setup and lastly the
use of space this diagram represents our
key synthesis of the disparate but
interwoven threads of the research field
and I'll have to admit to admit it's a
bit of a complicated diagram so let me
show you some examples across that
taxonomy first we have distributed user
interfaces which can either be spatially
or logically just distributed spatial
distribution means that the area of one
device continues and extends to other
devices and the video shows here shows a
simple example with a geographical map
that spans across a number of tablets
our taxonomy then points to a number of
relevant techniques for spatial
distribution such as an axon stitching
or perspective aware interfaces as the
second category of disturbed interfaces
we have logical distribution on the
right which describes how user
interfaces or elements are logically
distributed across multiple devices and
related techniques here are the seamless
or continuous you is multiple
coordinated views and interface beaming
and most of the examples we've seen in
Saul's presentation fit into that
category over here now here's another
example of recent work that we did we
build a platform for flexible ad hoc
cross device setups called surface
constellation and this cross device
project falls into into the category of
logical distribution and also matches to
several of the categories across the
taxonomy overview you can see here so we
were interested in exploring how a
person could easily create ad hoc multi
device workspaces essentially by
combining a stack of tablet devices in
front of them in new ways
so our system provided us a hardware and
software platform that facilitates the
creation of such multi tablet workspaces
and let me show you just two examples of
what those were so first here user
setting up a three tablet visual
analytics workstation and instead of
just putting them flat in front of them
the platform allows to dynamically put
them together in the workspace in front
of them and also adding devices ad hoc
to the to the setup in this example
you've seen here's where the phone is
added as a control interface controlling
some of the information that are seen on
the tablets another example is a
multi-user gaming setup and in this
device assembly a person puts the
tablets together so
the share tablet in the center shows the
playing field while the user-facing
devices show the private view of each
users ladders and then each player can
easily access their own and the share
playing board just because of that
particular configuration so let's go
back to our tech sauna me there's a last
category in in this diagram I would like
to point out and that our migratory
interfaces this is about adaptive
interfaces that are capable of migrating
between multiple devices which are often
of different form factors and related
techniques here our continuity component
migration and other model-based
approaches and in her talk later
Caroline will actually explain a few of
the novel techniques to address
interaction challenges in that
particular space now overall this
taxonomy will synthesizes key
characteristics of the field of cross
device interaction and our hope is that
it can help to outline the scope and
pathways through the different
characteristics of future projects in
this area now after we know how to look
at the overall research field I would
like to now guide you through an
overview of interaction techniques for
fluid cross device interactions now so I
mentioned earlier that a major challenge
is how we can transfer content between
devices in in fluid interactions and
across all the interaction techniques we
looked at we identified three key phases
that those interaction techniques are
usually part of first the configuration
phase second the content engagement
phase and third the disengagement phase
which essentially is about disconnecting
cross device setups or ending an
interaction or application now across
all those phases we mapped out the
interaction techniques we found in the
literature using a number of input
modalities such as touch gestures and
device manipulation let's have a closer
look at the configuration phase which
addresses issues just as such a setting
up pairing or connecting devices now for
example proxemic interaction that's all
mentioned earlier part of the input
modality body gestures and the category
is essentially about leveraging
knowledge about a person's presence
turning or approach to initiate initiate
interactions or offering interactions
between people's devices here's another
example where input modality device
motion includes Ken's work of
synchronous gestures and related
approaches where key sensing events can
initiate pairing of devices now we can
now move to the second phase
the content engagement phase which
contains techniques that are aimed at
interacting or transferring content or
in other ways exploring data for example
a large body of prior work has looked at
how how to transfer content between
devices for example through dragging
pick and drop swiping flicking or other
gestures here's an example in a
technique from our previous work I
showed you this video in the beginning
of my talk where a person can simply use
flicking touch gestures to transfer
information across a number of devices
in front of them and to make this
interaction technique work we had to
build a system that senses the accurate
position and orientation of all those
devices over there and that creates a
lot of challenges that I'll come back to
just at the end of my talk now instead
of using touch testers we can go to
another input modality and actually use
free hand gestures around the device and
we build a simple example to illustrate
that technique where a person here can
hover with a hand above the tablets they
can pick up objects and move them across
the screens of those multiple tablets in
front of them
now of course systems and techniques
don't have to strictly fall into one of
those categories over here and in fact I
would argue that some of the most
powerful techniques are hybrids
involving multiple input modalities and
an example of this was the gradual
engagement pattern that's all mentioned
earlier which spans across a number of
those different input modalities this
overview of interaction it can also help
us to identify where there gaps in prior
research and for example we found that
there are not many techniques that cover
the disengagement phase and this third
phase is concerned with interaction
techniques for a person to stop cross
device content engagement and on a
device on infrastructure application
level implemented for those techniques
and I think that for any real-world
deployments of cross device interaction
techniques it will be critical for us to
find appropriate techniques in this
phase now I'll stop here with my summary
of interaction techniques there are a
number of other categories and taxonomy
that you might be interested in covering
realization techniques tracking
technology evaluation and application
domains but I'll not go into more
details of those and instead I would
like to now have a closer look at number
three here at the techniques for cross
device interact I would close with the
question of what are the open issues
and where can we go where can we go go
next now we synthesized nine key themes
and challenges and opportunities in in
our taxonomy and due to time constraints
I'll only focus on three of those first
how do we tell people what they can do
with their devices and how to do it and
that's a relatively general problem in
HCI
for sure so while cross device
capabilities in recent years started to
appear in commercial products
studies have shown controversial
findings about their use and for example
studies with continuity showed that
users have challenges in understanding
its features they also not aware of its
presence and effects and they're also
unclear about how to mitigate the
significant privacy issues when devices
are shared and the underlying challenge
here is in communicating the action
possibilities and benefits of cross
device interaction in systems and
applications and most specifically I
would argue that we do need new concepts
feedback and possibly also feed-forward
mechanism as well as user interface
patterns that are designed specifically
for cross device computing second
designing new cross device systems
involves tackling challenges of social
relations and norms privacy
authentication as well as providing
support for the configuration work
needed in the engagement and
disengagement phase or showed you
earlier our analysis found that lack of
interaction techniques in the
disengaging phase from cross device
interactions in particular but new users
need the ability to configure and
reconfigure cross device functionality
and interactive systems need to
explicitly support opting in and opting
out mechanisms and as shown earlier in
seoul's talk the notions of proximity
and proxemics micro mobility in other
nuances of social context can be
leveraged when designing cross device
systems third much of the enabling
technology for cross device interactions
in our research space of HCI is
prototypical difficult to set up
expensive and requires a lot of space
and on a technical level cross device
research needs more practical testing
and refinement for situations outside of
the research lab to deploy wider scale
use and and for in the while deployments
and here are just a few examples of our
of our relatively complex tracking
infrastructures that were needed for the
examples are showed you earlier and
there's an interesting of
Trinity to design specialized inside our
tracking approaches devices that are
aware of only some of the nuances of the
context around them these are the steps
towards real-world deployment of cross
device work robust mobile and supporting
ad-hoc situations and research in
researchers in academia and Industry
have begun to point out and tackle this
infrastructure problem but only a few
efforts have focused on minimizing setup
and configuration time on the user's
part of enabling interactions
out-of-the-box now with this I would
like to end our journey through the
cross device interaction space and our
taxonomy in particular and my goal was
to give an overview of the field to
provide a synthesis of some of the
techniques allowing fluid cross device
interactions and to summarize a few
issues and opportunities my hope is that
some of the characteristics and
techniques are briefly mentioned here
can inspire future work of interactions
across devices and also look forward to
some discussions either as part of this
panel on the remaining time of the
faculty summit over here thank you very
much thank you so much Nick so we have
time for perhaps one question and then
we defer lots of the discussion at the
end so one question about this Oh
so let's move on and well we'll revisit
thank you thank you Nick
alright I'll come to our next speaker
maybe maybe we should say thank you or
next year so what's your name again so
this is Ken Hinkley and actually happens
to be my manager the founder of four
group epic
he's been at Microsoft Research since
1997 is the the master of pen and touch
and contacts and things done so many
publication I just still need to catch
up and read demo and I invite you to do
so
and he's going to share some of his
insight today with us about cross device
interaction all right thanks Natalie
indeed I am Ken and I'm thrilled to have
you all here on our campus today so I'd
like to share with you a few thoughts on
how we can take a
practical approach to sensing across
both devices and context my hope is to
put some of these social theory
motivated concepts that Saul talked
about into action in a compelling way
that real people can use without having
to sense everything but I want to be
clear at the outset here that I don't
have all the answers so I'm going to
draw in a few examples from research but
this is also an area where we have some
new work in progress so let me start by
harkening back to one of the great
examples that Saul's group explored
these totally succeeded in showing the
importance of social theory concepts
like proxemics but technically the
system collects a great deal of
information there's markers on every
device and there's all these special
cameras that are kind of hidden all over
to track everything so it's not at all
clear how to take this further out into
the wilderness of the real world or to
take this whole infrastructure that Nick
and I built together um you know it
enables some really neat stuff but the
second you walked outside these little
orange boxes on the carpet never mind
outside the lab never mind in the wild
all the magic of the system completely
fizzled so if we want real and practical
device ecologies we have to ask what can
we do with much more limited but still
nuanced notions of context or to say it
another way how far can just a bit of
sensing get us and I think there's room
for great creativity in this direction
so my main message is that practical
approaches that combine interaction
design with nuanced but incomplete
sensing have great promise it's nuanced
because as we'll show we can sense some
interesting subtleties but it's
incomplete because we don't try or even
aspire to sense everything and the limit
that has the potential to be harmful we
want practical systems that leave people
in control while hopefully avoiding some
of the types of dark patterns that Saul
alluded to that might be enabled by more
ubiquitous tracking infrastructures and
for all these reasons micro ability and
how it can scaffold proxemic
interactions of is a particular interest
to me
but first you sorta have to pay
attention here to what I call the scene
but unnoticed let's circle back to this
example from Saul and take a closer look
this time at the woman in the center in
particular so notice how our possessions
reinforce a proxemic message of distance
her bags protecting her like a shield
she's got sunglasses in case there's any
doubt of that message and even the book
she holds kind of forms this little
intimate cocoon close to her person
so that's a very subtle example of micro
mobility in everyday life in this case
and it's an unmistakable cue of don't
bother me and it's manifesting the
object she holds and places around her
person let's take another quick example
that actually came from some of the
studies that Nick and I did back when he
was here as an intern far too long ago
he's making me feel old here and this
hands even more strongly at how much we
might deal with lightweight sensing of
certain cues so in this example two
people are having a discussion and the
guy on it's sort of the beige polo shirt
is showing us information but now the
guy in the black jacket decides he has a
point he wants to make and so he starts
just raising his device very subtly
before even begin speaking while this
other person is still making their point
and then all he does is pick up his
device then instantly the other guys
kind of puts his surface down so these
are you know very lightweight and subtle
cues to grab attention in the
conversation but it can be totally
effective and this is how people use
these sort of micro mobility cues in the
physical objects they hold to and and
furthermore nuances of how they hold
move angle and grip devices to
communicate non-verbally so let's go
into a few examples here all right and I
want to start really simple this is like
a little unpublished project we have it
was done in collaboration with Caroline
student Hugo Roman and also Professor
Christopher Collins so Microsoft Surface
duty you may have seen it it's
essentially this little mini drafting
table and you can adjust it and hold
this angle there really nice to work
with but it only gives you a single
degree of freedom of movement but what
if you could sense even just that this
very limited form of micro ability what
can you do with that
[Music]
flat knoweth the user can create
personal information such as sticky
notes tilting the surface up high it's
personal content the user can create
content and annotate it in OneNote
tilting the surface up transforms this
annotated content into a presentation we
have prototyped interaction techniques
for both discrete and continuous layers
which take advantage of the unique
tilting capabilities of the surface
devices provided functions which are
natural and ergonomically appropriate to
each of the tilt angles all right so you
can see it's you know it's very simple
there's no major miracle requires
miracles required to pull this off and
we could weave these kind of micro
mobility inspired interactions into
everyday digital activity and our
collaborations listen let me go into one
other example here this is work that was
led by Don woo Hyun about five years ago
where we went just a bit further with
the sensing and tried to include some
details of the hand graphs that can add
further nuances to device micro mobility
and there's ideas here that applied to
multiple users with one device or even a
single user with multiple devices
because sometimes you people use Mike
more ability even to hold and direct
their own attention how you just hold
and menu play physical documents so just
a nature vocabulary for interacting with
digital documents with device micro
mobility that is the way people
employees total orientation and
repositioning of artifact to help steer
the focus of attention in a joint
activity micro mobility also allows us
to detect and accommodate social norms
is in a natural and fluid manner
collaborators often past habits in
face-to-face interactions our
face-to-face handle technique switches
to a guest profile when the user passes
the tablet in this manner we have
demonstrated a number of techniques that
combine fine grain that have the
aggressive sensing with the micro
mobility of the device over all these
techniques demonstrate and contribute
our unique interplay between user
aggressive device movement and
orientation during both individual and
collaborative activities and I want to
re-emphasize there that all the sensing
is just these few simple things in the
tablet there's no sort of global
tracking system in the room like we're
showing Saul and mixed systems so here's
another example because these same ideas
could apply to tablet but there's more
varieties of use in these these contexts
because tablets afford frequent
transitions between stationary and
mobile use indeed if you look closely
again at this sort of scene but
unnoticed way that people hold their
devices there's a whole zoo of postures
here and so to support the full richness
of micro ability we're gonna need to
properly transition in between these
fine-grained cost contexts of use it
also sort of takes some of the sensing
things we started exploring on loops
project and kind of updates them to more
modern sensors that I think are more
practical and you hopefully deploy a
below to distant future okay so in this
one we're using three particular
modalities and two of them already built
into the screen so one is the touch
screen itself but now we can actually
access the full heat map the full raw
image of the touch screen of course we
also use the standard tilts and
accelerometer information for the device
because I always do that
and finally the interesting bit here is
there's a custom peripheral electrical
field sensor which gives us grip plus
the proximity of the hand and forearm to
the screen bezel even when it's not
actually touching it out to about you
know say five centimeters or so but it's
just a capacitive sensor that plausibly
could be built into the device chassis
all right so here's a little
demonstration of this when you grasp the
tablet grip centric thumb tools appear
if the grip changes the thumb tools
follow sometimes it's unclear where to
best put the tools just tilt to tip them
one way or the other
putting the tablet down flat returns the
tools to a more standard device centric
pallet when you settle down to write or
sketch
pop tools appear these miniature tools
are easy to reach with the pen and let
you stay focused on the work at hand the
fan tools appear when you hold two
fingers so on the desktop
you can work with both hands when you
let go the fan tools disappear but when
you work with one hand the fan tools
stay posted posture awareness lets us
gracefully degrade the interaction to
suit mobile use even the pen can act as
a tangible problem they see it on the
screen reveals all of its hidden
properties and options for the pen tip
the pen button and the eraser you can
even use the pen as a container for
photos or whole applications overall we
have seen how posture awareness can
adapt interaction and morph user
interface elements to suit the
fine-grained context of use this
includes crimp the angle of the tablet
which hand the user employees and other
nuances of touch including tangible
props but in the tablet savvy way
suitable for mobile use
all right psyche is your sense of sort
of all these very fine-grained contexts
we can detect even just a single users
use of a tablet I wanted to hearken back
to one sort of older example that goes
even for this idea of instead of sensing
more actually sensing much less and it
also shows how we can still inform our
design with proxemics and other aspects
of social theory this was work that was
done by Gonzalo Ramos who's him here at
MSR now back when he was an intern with
me in 2003 I think but it's still very
relevant because it also as you see in
the video it dates from this era when
displays didn't even have pen and touch
yet so it's it's it's it's it's from a
few years back but I think so quite
interesting and here the only sensor is
the pen itself so we can see or it also
could work with touch gestures as well
and these modalities have this sort of
one superpower which is that compared to
a mouse they're not bound by the screen
they can actually span multiple displays
as you move back and forth
there's no other sensor here but the pen
itself salami stitching contributes a
new way for users to share information
and to forge dynamic connections between
distributed wireless devices by using
pen gestures that span multiple displays
by selecting a photo and making a
continuous pen gesture on to the other
screen the pen stroke itself specifies
the two machines
note that the graphical feedback appears
to span the bezel between the displays
even if we arrange the tablets
differently as another example if I want
to give a presentation of selected
photos to another user I can select an
image to start with stitch the other
screen and choose gallery from the menu
the other computer then displays a
full-screen view of those images I
select on the first tablet users can
employ the transporter to give photos to
another user even if that user is no
longer nearby if the user drags a photo
to the edge of the screen and dwells
with the pen after a brief pause that
photo is transported to the other device
we can support the technique on tablet
PCs as well as other devices such as the
Pocket PC our stitching technique
supports pen gestures between screens
and any of these orientations all right
now there one other detour up to mention
there is that the way the system knows
which other devices synchronize with is
just through wireless signal strength so
it kind of has a sense of which devices
are proximal in a very coarse-grained
manner alright so I wanted to just show
one more thing very quickly and sort of
a plug for an ongoing effort where we're
trying to revisit all these issues and
take them a bit further and it's a
project that we're calling surface fleet
it tries to bring some of these concepts
into a toolkit in example applications
of device ecologies for what we call a
society of devices experience so at this
at this stage is sort of still an
ongoing effort so we're still kind of
this stage where like we think there's
something interesting here we haven't
quite figured out what it is yet but we
think it'll be it'll be fun and
hopefully well paper at upcoming chi or
whis conferences in particular the
surface fleet toolkit builds on top of a
system called Ambrosia which is done by
Jonathan Goldstein here at Microsoft
Research and it provides robustness to
failure through performance database
abstractions
and ambrosia is already available as a
fully open source toolkit on github and
you can download and play with it now if
you like however we're adding layers
that run communicate and synchronize
application state and all the kind of
sensor events that we like to play with
across multiple devices so here's kind
of our dream team working on some
compelling applications and showing you
know interesting ways they might using
micro ability I guess you know maybe
it's a you know album cover for a new
techno band - I don't know but since all
surface fleet applications are
inherently distributed it naturally
encourages one to re-envision cross
device activities and ecosystems but we
shall see so perhaps this can let us
take notions like distributed micro
mobility in the next level in a really
practical manner
alright so to conclude I saw advocated
so well we need to draw insights and
inspiration from social science theory
but practical approaches that can work
outside the lab will need to combine
interaction designs that leave users in
control rather than trying to infer
everything with nuanced but incomplete
sensing amenable to mass-produced
devices my hope is this perspective can
spark fresh ideas for practical
Ecology's of devices and of course we'd
love your insights
perhaps wrong all were missing is an
epiphany or two and a little bit more
imagination thank you very much thank
you very much of time for perhaps one
question before the end come on people
no let's defer to the end thank you
Carrie
alright I have the pleasure to introduce
our next speaker Karolina pair from
University of Paris suit of parachute in
France France so she flew all the way
here to talk to you guys so Carolyn is a
research scientist and she's been
working a lot with innovative
interaction techniques where they're on
desktop on tablets with gestures and
then more recently tangible interaction
thank you Carrie
Thank You Natalie so I'm very happy to
be here so oh sorry I don't see my notes
my notes are not showing up so I'm the
only one taking risk using this
sophisticated and setup but I have I
don't have them yes I know you thought
okay now so yes I really sir you can see
that I rely on my on my present L notes
so it's not a secret so in this talk I
will take inspire inspiration from
projects I have been working on to
discuss how we can lower the cost for
transitioning from one device to another
so let's start from a concrete example
so I'm working on my presentation for
the Microsoft faculty submit on my
laptop interface on the left and I want
to continue on my way to the office in
the public transportation so I want to
move my rock and barrel environment from
my laptop to my smartphone interface on
the right however it's not as simple as
I wanted to be so first I have to
explicitly save my presentation in my
drive from my laptop
after having signed in in the cloud once
my presentation is in the cloud then I
can access it from my smart phone but I
am not done yet and I still have a
significant number of interaction steps
to complete I have to launch PowerPoint
on my smart phone
then navigate files in my drive from
there after having made sure that I have
that I am signed in and still I'm not
done yet
I have to navigate in my presentation to
get to the slide I was actually working
on on my laptop so here we have an
illustration of a first problem the
number of interaction steps for
transitioning from one device to another
and it's not the only problem so it's
quite often that the difference in
screen sizes make the UI look different
on two different devices so for example
for example once on my smart phone I
don't know anymore
what I should do to adjust the font size
so why I knew where this control was on
my laptop I have no idea where it is now
on my smart phone
so in the end
while the cloud makes it possible to
access data independently from the
device I am working on interaction
remains very dependent on the device so
in the rest of this talk I will point
out three potentially interesting
directions to lower the cost when
transitioning from one device to another
so I will talk about tangibles augmented
reality and gestures so I start with
tangibles so intangible interfaces
somedy physical objects can be used to
interact with the digital world
literature on tangibles for interaction
mentions many entrants interesting roles
tangibles can play they can serve as
controllers data containers filters they
can also act as user identifier in
collaborative context and so on
tangey bars are usually small meaning
that they are easy to transport and they
are simple so the usually support a
limited number of manipulations that
require no or little training but the
problem with tangible interfaces that is
that they are often difficult to
implement other require clumsy equipment
in order to make tangible objects able
to communicate with a digital system so
it's usually done either by putting
cameras in the environment and
implementing vision based algorithms or
by embodying some electronics in both
the tangibles and the system to make
them able to communicate but he not
touch certain projects we have shown
that tangible interfaces can be not so
costly to implement so this is what we
can see on this video where the designer
simply downloads a vector description of
the Turcan set and then uses it to laser
cut off 3d prints simple tokens and then
they finally download the libraries that
can recognize those tokens and
developers can implement share
applications using the simple API that
we provided so the principle so why is
it so quick to build a tangible
interfaces with a touch tokens is that
because the principle is quite it's
actually quite simple so as you can
maybe you have noticed that tokens
feature notches that indicates how to
grasp them and each token features a
different configuration of notches so
then when a token is
detectives your face we can recognize a
touch pattern that is representative of
the token so this simple solution makes
the chickens work on any textured
surface on my trackpad my smartphone on
a tabletop and this also means that
touch tokens can be made of any non
conductive material so let's go through
a series of simple demos to show the
kind of things we can do with tangible
interactions so here for example we use
coloured acrylic tokens to control a
scatter plot visualization oh the sound
sensor can we put this on DAF sorry so
here you can see the chickens made of
transparent transparent acrylic Zac tag
the tag does physical physical magic
lenses so there is no need to embed the
electronics in touch tokens they can be
fully transparent which is interesting
here because one token is associated
with one matte layer so I can see the
mana the corresponding correspondingly
map layer through the token would it be
possible to turn the sound off for the
next things as a video so we also
developed a demo when we use tokens to
control access to some applications so
here in this video some application
icons are disabled so these applications
can't be launched with a with a simple
touch users actually need the
corresponding token to launch the expec
a launch the application so with with
such a simple simple interaction I can
control access to some stuff on my Tibet
I can land my tablet to my kids and keep
the token for for my emails for example
for the email application and finally
finally here we have a simple game
application where users so typically
kids here have to dock physical tokens
into their silhouettes that he displayed
on the screen so getting back to our
transition problem so we had if you
remember we had to sign-in twice once on
each device savedata in the cloud launch
the application navigated to the slide
we were working on and where I was
thinking when preparing the site we
could use a token
well to have just a single interaction
steps to actually move my work
environment from one device to another
so I just put the token for example on
my laptop's trackpad to capture my
current work context and then I put the
same token on my smartphone to get this
context restored so this idea is based
on the series of demos that we have just
seen Americans can be used to control
access thus signing in a transparent way
and then can be associated with data in
commands so here's a token will be
associated with the presentation tries
the application name and the application
state to restore the complete work
environment and I could use the same
token to move to any other available
device because touch tokens can work on
any textured surface so for example I
can also move on my tablet or even on
the world side screen that is a world
size screen that is available in my lab
so moving to another advantage of the
tokens something that I didn't mention
is that tangible objects are very
interesting because they provide added
haptic feedback when we manage when we
manipulate them so this property can be
interesting to make several devices work
together where one device is used to
remote control of another device so
let's take this a concrete example of
his remote where users can control the
PowerPoint PowerPoint slide deck that
runs on an one digital screen from a
simple UI display on John Spartan
actually here I have a tangible
interface but you could have an app - an
app on your own on your smart phone but
if the presenter wants to keep her
attention on the audience and not look
at the smartphone
she is typically limited to very simple
gestures that basically support next and
previous slide only because otherwise
more complex gestures or precise button
would require me to look precisely to
the smartphone and using tokens will
make it possible to get much more
elaborate controls that would remain
operable ice-free so for example tokens
could be could make her able to control
a video player or even even do some data
storage data storytelling so she could
manipulate a token for example protein
eat squid meat rotate
you need to interactively filter
information or emphasize interesting
parts in the infographics for a more
engaging presentation so more controlled
high highs free well okay so we've
talked about tangible interactions they
are cool but they can represent quite a
big move for a company like Microsoft
but if we think about it's actually some
Microsoft devices are accompanied by a
tangible object which is the pen but the
typical interaction paradigm we revisit
Bennie's one pen writes on one device
only so if we draw a parallel with what
we have seen with tangible interfaces
it's quite different from the idea of
having several tokens that can play many
roles in the interaction so for example
we can wonder why whether having
multiple pens in some contexts for
example in the office could be a good
thing instead of playing with small UI
components to change one pens drawing
style we could switch between several
physical and specific pens another thing
we have seen that using tokens across
devices can be interesting so we can
think that we can think that the same
would stand with pens but as for today
one pen is paired with a unique device
thus making it impossible to perform
some cross divined cross device
interactions so this might be good to
reconsider but from what I've seen when
I was preparing this talk it seems that
the new Microsoft Surface surface pen
will work on several surfaces so that's
good and I final things that we can
point out is that a pen usually writes
which makes perfect sense but at the
same time there is no major reason to
limit pens function to writing for
examples it could be used for
transferring data and why not assign
meaning on my device so let's now move
to the next part of my talk how can
augment it reality help lower the cost
when transitioning from one device to
another so getting back to our initial
problem again so I mentioned that to you
I can look quite different on two
different devices so for example I know
how to change the font size on
a point on my desktop but I don't know
how to do it on my smartphone oops okay
so what I might be interested here is to
get some support to show me the mapping
between the interface I am familiar with
the desktop one and the interface I am
new to the smartphone one this is well
augmented reality could play a role for
example here I hold my smart phone I
don't know where the phone size control
is on my smart phone so thanks to our
glazed glasses I could have both
interfaces displayed in the same place
so AR shows me the desktop UI
I am familiar with and I can then point
at one familiar UI component here the
font size I don't know if you notice the
small cursor moves move an AR show me
shows me where to find it
this same control on my on my smart
phone here an arrow shows me the button
with three dots I tap on it and AR now
occurs where the UI component for
adjusting the font size is so the idea
of mapping to interfaces by means of
augmented reality is not a specific
scenario I have been I have actually
worked on however it is such uses of AR
that motivate the need for an efficient
way of interacting with wizard - Divya
toward objects this failure displayed in
your headset screen but the thing is
that for now such interactions are quite
difficult so even simply pointing at an
object is not so easy so it usually
relies on gaze which is quite fast but
with some drawbacks so it's fun to
activate or accidental activations and
it make the viewport move so which
causes some objects leave leave the hint
of you so an alternative could consist
in using direct pointing with hands in
front of the headset but it causes
fatigue very quickly so what we are
currently looking at is whether indirect
pointing can work in augmented reality
so with indirect pointing users make
movement in a virtual plane which is not
co-located with that of the screen and
movements control yourself which is
displayed in the headset screen so it's
typically
we do on a laptop when we move our
fingers on the trackpad to make the
cursor move on the screen so trackpad
and the screen are not correlated so we
are currently running a study to
identify where and how to position this
midair imaginary trackpad relative to
the users body so the idea is to put it
in the position that bus and shells
compatible movements and efficient scene
pointing so we considered out the waist
the sir
yes the the way the wrist and the thigh
and we also look at the orientation for
such a fossil the orientation of such a
batch such a pad such a media trackpad
should be so parallel to the screen or
not so why do we do that if we think
about a desktop trackpad the trackpad
splaying
is not parallel to that of the screen
and we want to see whether such a
difference in relative orientation also
works in augmented reality so for the
last part of my talk I will quickly
discuss the use of gestures across
across devices so we have seen that
visual consistency between the same
application on two devices can be a
problem one way of getting rid of some
visual UI components is to rely on
gestures for activating commands but the
problem with gestures that the number of
simple gestures is limited plus one
gesture can be appropriate from one
device and quite uncomfortable on
another device so just to take a simple
example the usual pinch and rotate
gestures is much more uncomfortable to
perform on the vertical surfaces than it
is on a horizontal surface so one
solution consists in allowing several
allowing several variations of our
gesture to activate the same command so
users can choose the variations a judge
the most comfortable for the device they
are interacting with so this is what we
have done in this project where gesture
recognition is based on some gesture
properties as opposed to to be on their
actual shape so for example we consider
with our gestures it is anchored or not
which means that
teachers at least one needlepoint during
its execution honored and those are
properties whether a gesture follows a
linear trajectory or a circular one and
the last example of such a property is
whether a gesture features a point
within its envelope that remains
environed during its execution kind of
reference point so by recognizing some
properties as opposed to the exact
gestures it makes it possible for users
to perform different variations of the
same gesture so for example these two
gestures that you can see on the bottom
right so they are the same it's actually
the same command but one is more
appropriate for a small handheld screen
like a tablet while the other is more
appropriate for a large vertical screen
like a surface hub and in this project
were so pay particular attention and
designing gestures that can be
recognized in real time as opposed to
many research projects that propose
gestures that are recognized a
posteriori which means once users have
finished them
so here the gesture properties that we
consider are local ones this means that
they can be recognized in real time so
just just can not only be used for
continuous control like a pinch gesture
is used to continuously to continuously
adjust the zoom factor but it also means
that users can freely transition from
one gesture to another so this makes it
possible to change to chain commands
such as said typeface set the typeface
and the font size or such as resizing an
object and rated in it in the same
interaction so here we can see three
small videos of three possible types of
such transitions so they are very short
videos that shows I'm doing two
different gestures without removing my
hands from the tablet
and that's it for me thank you for your
attention thank you Karen we have time
for one question for Carolyn before we
move on to the panel you want question
oh all right so let's get our first
speaker back on stage please q so we
have now time for sort of forum or you
know relaxed conversation maybe he's
like ceded by question from the audience
or like bigger question for the whole
set of perspective that we had today on
that topic is there a couple of people
wanted to see the question or two hello
my name is pear boat a Mogan I'm from
Washington State University and my
question is I was just watching that
room that you had the test run of the
three men that were just kind of moving
things and proximity and how that was
related is that now like or was that
like it maybe a couple years ago or is
that where you guys currently are right
now are you talking about the
information
yeah the affirmation the room where I
don't really know how to describe it
well you guys yeah well there were a few
studies done but um the mean the image I
showed at least of showing sort of that
micro mobility I know people lift
tablets I was from a study that Nick and
I did in 2011 I think and and then we
just we actually just used form cord
display boards as proxies for physical
tablets so we didn't really want to
focus so much in the weight and form
factor and and and it was a totally I
mean that was not a staged shot that I
had in my talk it was totally just
naturalistic things that just occurred
and we were capturing a video and just
pulled out some of the key frames there
just show what happens so these are kind
of very deeply baked behaviors I think
they probably do change somewhat with
you know over time people like
for example I can run when the you know
sort of the Bluetooth headsets first
came out and people would be talking to
themselves like cuz they're going on the
street like I found that really weird
but you know I'm also getting kind of
old at this point right so I think
people do adapt culturally over time but
I think these sort of implicit behaviors
just showing things to people how close
we are these are sort of across all
cultures like the exact rules vary but
but the distance always matters you know
the exact threshold might be different
cultures but just since always matters
how you hold things always matters so I
think there are universal things but it
would be nice to kind of revisit that
with modern devices that are getting
lighter thinner different sizes
different form factors emerging and see
what kind of new sort of proxemics or
micro mobility behaviors might be
emerging currently as well - Alicia are
you from University of Toronto thank you
so very much for all of those fantastic
talks I was a bit distracted with some
emails here and there but I saw like
many great fantastic ideas out there so
these ideas are still be disconnected
for me and actually I have troubles
because I'm not working in this space
like seeing that like the big picture or
like where we're headed to so I was
curious to know if you had to work all
four of you together and write a paper
that is what are the next challenge is a
big challenges for cross-device
interaction what would and I would love
to see this paper coming actually so
what would be those like a big big big
challenges most pressing challenges or
like big interesting opportunities well
I can start that a little bit first many
of us have actually worked together over
the years Nick and can and I have have
done a lot of work together and that's
why he saw so many of the slides and the
same in our presentations I think the
you know I think there's a lot of big
challenges like one of the things that
really concerns me is that we're trying
to build on social practices which is a
really good thing to mean that people
just get it they understand that they
know what to do you know given a proper
a feedback they just they just
understand what's happening the concern
for me is that that can be played as
well by plate I mean that it's that
whole dark pattern side of things where
can somebody spoof the system can
somebody actually access information on
your device or push information on it
when you don't want it and there's some
of the mechanisms here kind of showed
how you can start safeguarding about it
but part of that is how do you build
Federation's of devices and I think the
eff formations work was one of that was
how do we decide what devices are joined
together which ones are outside it or
what actions will trigger that so for
example is the stitching that Ken showed
where you you essentially have to have a
continuity of an action across the
device which is very visible to all the
participants can help that as well
dissenting the sensing aspect how do you
actually sense information without it
being in the cloud so you know that
everything is local I'm really concerned
about that because maybe it's just me
getting older but I see a lot of
Technology design where we think here's
all the great stuff we can do but
without thought into into here's the bad
stuff a lot was sort of rambling but but
but in essence there's a lot of big
challenges the sensing the safeguarding
the fluidity understanding social norms
making sure that people get it putting
that into standard practice all that is
part of the challenges and I'm sure
these guys and girls have some other
other things that's a great summary
there's the article already yeah but I
one thing that I thought also thought
about when you asked about the the big
challenges I think a particular bit that
I that I showed you earlier with
interaction techniques we try to map out
is that it sometimes felt like it and
and definitely my own work probably
falls into that category that we come up
with a lot of interaction techniques
that are often feel quite specialized
but then we argue they kind of
generalize across it so we're kind of in
that mishmash in the middle somewhere
where I think future direction could be
interesting to find out a few techniques
which which are generalized become more
out of a general vocabulary of
techniques at the one end of the
spectrum and at the other end of the
spectrum are then identifying those
particular techniques that are very
targeted at one particular use case or a
very small particular use case instead
of staying too much in the middle and I
think that's something that could be
quite interesting to to do over the next
few years and one thing that is are so
important you know in my opinion is that
you focused a lot on your industry talks
in collaborative contexts where you have
several devices for several users but
actually as Natalie pointed out that at
the beginning we have many
configurations now we're one people has
many devices and in that case
safeguarding is is a different problem
it still is because you don't want
something for example from with hands
off with a banner which I put my my
smartphone close to my laptop
something might show up without actually
yeah I clearly keep control on it on my
on my screen and I don't want others to
to actually be on my shoulder in search
order and see what was on my smartphone
but so I think also studying this
problem of the constellation of devices
from one user is something that we
should push further and my my take would
be your so that's something an
additional device like tangible so smell
your glasses can play a big role in that
so so I have two answers as well that
the first one is that we have not
written the paper challenges across
device interaction because it'd be a
really long paper the second is that
another big challenge is that if you use
some of these natural behaviors people
have and you kind of overload them with
technical meetings like like oh I lift
up my phone and like suddenly Clippy
pops up in my screen right that that it
actually coops the using that for human
human communication right zestar the
other challenge is like how do you let
people still interact naturally in the
real world whether maybe they happen to
holding my phone and I'm talking to saw
but I'm really not concerned with doing
something there so you have to somehow
leave the user control or have some sort
of you know explicit gating mechanism
where there's some
tenshun ality to the inter options or
maybe a few can be sensed in the
background in clever ways but you don't
want to sort of smash the the natural
human interaction because like we
actually still like to actually talk to
people occasionally thank you
um so Dan Angus from Queensland
University of Technology I've got a
question around I guess what I see is a
challenge for us in this space which is
that everybody brings different devices
to the table right and these are owned
by different proprietary corporations
and and and interacting in different
kind of media ecologies which are I
guess from where I sit seem to be moving
more towards a walled garden space right
if we look at social media companies and
their kind of appetite for controlling
more and more of the the space and more
and more of our data how do we move back
against this and how do we deal in an
environment where a lot of gestures and
interaction types are also patented or
protected and so we're restricted not
just in the creative space but in actual
implementation of what would be a really
nice say naturalistic gesture we can't
actually do that because that would say
you know move up against a pattern or
something how do we how do we move
forward in this space that's really
interesting like one of the other things
I've been doing over the last few years
has been working as an expert witness
for IP and IP cases and you're
absolutely right the things that people
are suing each other on are insane and
they're the most micro smallest things
you can imagine in a patent that they
generalize to include everything in the
world I take heart that if you go back
to the Xerox star back in you know what
here was that that wasn't it well 83
yeah thanks Bill
Bill is the only one of us who was
younger than the rest of us were born
sorry bill the there one of the concepts
and this was mentioned before was was
what are the universal commands that
apply everywhere and I think if you look
back on that I can't remember the exact
ones but the the things that we now take
for granted like cut copy paste
point those kind of things they were all
provided back then and they were
universally adopted by all the vendors
how do we make that happen today I
actually don't know in this day of
protectionism but perhaps the best way
to make it happen is by having a lot of
people start complaining about hey you
know my Apple device doesn't talk to my
Samsung device which doesn't talk to my
other device at some point maybe it'll
be seen as a benefit to the various
companies involved to say that yes we do
it is actually a beneficial and actually
economic sense to actually support
cross-device experiences so it strike hi
Abilene I'm from University of
illinois-chicago
so I really like the whole idea of cross
device experiences came from the social
theory of próxima makes art alright but
when that fury came up there was not a
visible formation with two people
looking at their phones what what's
happening right now so my question is
now that you guys have worked on cross
device experiences for so long using the
fury what do you think about going back
and updating or informing back to the
social sciences is there anything that
you have learned that we can go back and
update or inform or change anything from
the proxemics one quick answer I would
have is that I searched around the some
of those old social theories and like
other than Micra mobility which actually
came from the HCI and see scw literature
there's there's actually not much
discussion of that in the sociological
literature that I've been able to find
maybe I just don't know the right
keyword but it's also literature it's
very hard to search online because it's
mostly dates from the 1960s and it's
hard to find things but there's been
very little study of how objects mediate
these sort of formations so kind of the
example you stated where you know people
standing face to face by maybe they're
on their individual phones so my sense
and I've you know I've sort of poked
around this and a couple papers I've
written but haven't really formalized it
is that there is a notion of device
proxemics that's somewhat connected to
human you know body space proxemics but
exactly how
you know holding a phone modulates my
personal space is unclear and hasn't
been studied that closely so I think
that's it would be a great topic for
someone to tackle if they if they're
interested or don't want to collaborate
with us but we haven't really done that
study other than just showing a few
examples like hey it looks like you know
the way you hold this phone course
tablet like it affects you know the
formation that people adopt for example
so there's definitely things there but
you know what exactly what are the
parameters of that what theories Drive
that is is still unknown I'd say in in
it it's interesting that you ask that
because I asked I actually asked Ken the
same questions was it yesterday where he
said do you know anything any theories
out there about what does actually means
to actually exchange a piece of paper
with someone else in linguistics they
look at the breakdowns of language down
to you know micro utterances and yet I
again maybe for the same use it could be
out there I don't know where it is that
I don't know if anybody's done any
actual work on actual physical exchange
and what happens with that you know the
whole give-and-take process like you
know the old thing of you know here here
take this in a grass it but none of us
are really going to let it go yeah I
think I I really don't want to give it
to you but you so all those little funny
things that happen in everyday life but
the good news is that we all know that
stuff - it's all tacit within us so it's
not we sometimes can't articulate what
it is but we kind of know when it breaks
just to comment on the previous question
they some of it those there are some
basic rules and there's simply what's
visible and that the moral order of
place and the social mores are what the
things are visible and it's really
interesting to see when you move things
from a phone like the photographs the
example from a phone to a laptop or
something back and forth there's magic
in the middle where it goes through this
middle space where it's invisible and if
we look at the surface table the
original surface table that Steve
petition Andy Wilson did what was really
important about that that teaches us
something is
when you put enough two phones on the
table and you're moving photographs
between the middle space was filled
because it was visible and you had this
foreground at the table which used to be
the foreground device became the
background and the foreground devices
were the tangible things on top and you
saw the transition and so as long as you
have that awareness of what's going on
and so when it's not possible to have
that background feedback the question is
and in some of the examples you did that
beautifully it was clear that they were
going because you had this continuity of
momentum and so that's where you don't
switch you have this analog flow you
established the trajectory your eyes
follow even if it's invisible and you
see it arrive and those types of
feedback or the things where you
preserve this knowledge of what went I
have confirmation and the examples show
that beautifully but it's all too rare
and that's one of the most important
lessons I think that came out of the 50
examples that you showed ok maybe is the
last question there whoever she minutes
left
Lucey Fortson University of Minnesota
can you elaborate on the sensing
technologies that will need to be
developed in order for us to get to the
point where we're not under a hub or
something like that
you alluded to a few things several of
you in your talks but I'm just sort of
interested from the engineering or
sensing side what actually are the next
steps that have to happen in order to
make this ubiquitous I think if I had
the answer I would put it in my talk
right yeah it's very tricky I mean like
so I mean a lot of the things that like
the like Saul and Nick in particular did
some great work exploring like what if
you have all this richness about where
people are standing where devices are
you kind of know all the the six degree
of freedom orientation of the devices
and people in the room and where they're
looking you can do some amazing stuff
with that it's unclear to me if there's
a nice technical path in the in the
near-term future say the next five to
ten years where we could actually get
there in a way that you could put in a
you know an iPad and it would be
everywhere
so that's a big challenge but you know
so part of it I think is having more
instead of outside in tracking where
it's like it's in the environment you
have to be in the special place for it
to work if it's inside out so maybe you
know some of the things like if you
think of the hololens type of device
Nonna's augmented reality but just
simply as a sensor that you walk around
with you know maybe that kind of hints
that if that was just on a device and
it's kind of looking out that gate that
gives you a hint of like you know maybe
that's how you could send spatial
relationships in a way that's scalable
but it also is still raises you know
privacy concerns like you know do people
consent to being tracked within this
thing I mean there's there's all kinds
of those kind of issues I think are
really difficult and I don't have the
faintest clue how to attack than being
perfectly frank you know one of the
things like as Ken mentioned we we
started this whole approach thinking
about what if we knew had almost perfect
knowledge of what was going on and what
we what could we do to design very
nuanced interfaces for for cross-device
interaction and also for person device
interaction which I didn't really show
show in the videos I think starting from
the other way is also really interesting
if we start by saying here are the
social the social norms we want to
provide how can we use existing
technology on our devices like you know
we have a lot of sensors on our devices
to actually follow some of those social
norms so can we use a camera on a device
to in a way that it actually recognizes
the other devices and enables some kind
of social norms so starting from the
minimal set could help give us insight
into what we can do with a minimal set
and I think your work where you you
started talking about how can just use
some kind of pretty simple sensors to do
that is a starting point but if you're
building toward the social norm and
that's what you're designing toward I
think you can actually get away with a
lot by using very simple sensors that
already exists on devices all right with
that well going to conclude it with food
for thoughts and future like challenges
we need to tackle and get food in our
belly thank you very much everyone
you
[Applause]